I'm absorbing it all sherry and I'm sure
it happens where people come back to and
they just say look this is it's too much
like this is this is too much work I
mean how do you respond to that well I
say I told you yesterday i was at
calarts and i was listening to some of
the classes that were going on there and
there it's the directing track so I'm
listening to what all the directors have
to do they have to know how to deal with
actors and and all the technical people
on the set and and composers and you
know their craft of how they're going to
set up shots and all this kind of stuff
and then you start putting on them and
the marketing I'm already overwhelmed by
all the stuff you have to do just to
bring this you know project into
fruition but I could I can see why this
is an overwhelming thing now that's not
an excuse to say it doesn't need to be
done it will have to be done and so you
will have to have some help you will
have to be able to delegate it's it's
it's not really possible and people
don't make films all by themselves this
is one of those aspects of things that
you can't do all by yourself probably
now do you have to have a team of 30
people know our team of five people know
you could do it with just a team of one
person and a few outsource jobs you know
a web designer to get your website up
he's not a full-time guy he's just doing
that until that's completed and then you
know you have other aspects to it that
are just sort of outside workers but you
would want to have somebody who
interfaces with those people that can
get that done and not or you're still
involved in the process but if you had
to be pulled off on something else you
could have that still taking care if it
doesn't fall to the ground while you're
sorting out a fire somewhere else but it
yeah it definitely is overwhelming and
the other question that I got was how do
you expect us to do all this stuff even
within our own professional life when
we're trying to get our movies made and
to that question I say especially for
people who can remember life without the
internet or life without social media
that there was a time when we didn't
have the internet and we didn't have
cellphones we
have email and we have had to fit those
into our life you know that we are now
expected to be contact about 24 hours a
day no matter of a keishon weekends
whenever and you haven't said well I'm
not doing email because I just don't
know how I'm gonna fit that in you
adapted you learn to fit that into your
schedule and this is one of those things
but also that if you really think of it
as a creative process something that you
naturally just use in your life to
bounce ideas off of people to network
with people it doesn't become like this
separated duty it kind of becomes part
of your life you can't imagine I mean I
can say that I'm probably already
addicted whenever I go somewhere I want
to take an Instagram picture you know of
something and share that and it's just
just is you know I don't think about oh
I should be taking pictures for
Instagram it's just like oh I see this
i'm gonna share it you know it doesn't
mean that people are going to
immediately respond and i'll have tons
of likes or whatever but it accumulates
you know it goes into your portfolio and
people can look at them later and that
kind of thing so I know production
people get used to new programs new
software new equipment that comes out
and they've got to learn it and they
figure it out they you know know that
they have to stay on top of that for
their craft adaptability is something
that they have to have and so this is
one of those adaptability issues that's
going to have to start being
incorporated
you